- Bonsoir Patrice.
- Vous êtes à Montréal, plus
difficile d'exercer son métier
de journaliste à Moscou.
- Impossible avec les standards
qu'on se donnait à la liberté à
laquelle on est habitué. On a
suspendu pendant quelque temps
les opérations de Moscou mais on
encore un bureau et on espère
retourner bientôt.
- Très bien, on a demandé hier
au public de nous envoyer des
questions. On n'en a choisi
quelques-unes, je vais vous les
poser. D'abord, quel est le
risque que Poutine utilise
l'arme nucléaire sachant que les
membres de l'OTAN répliqueraient
avec force en Russie?
- C'est une très bonne question,
c'est de la question qu'on ne
veut pas se poser à la fois
haute parce qu'elle est
terrorisante. On ne penserait
pas avoir eu à se poser ces
questions 2020 : la menace
nucléaire est en train de dicter
la réponse de l'OTAN. La Russie
est une puissance nucléaire et
pas n'importe laquelle. Elle
partage la moitié s
nucléaires avec les États-Unis.
La pierre angulaire des
relations américaines et russes
depuis l la guerre
froide édictée par le risque ou
la peur d'une collision
militaire. On saite. On saite. e
collision militaire entre ces
deux pays la pourrait dégénérer
en guerre nucléaire. Il a brandi
Poutine, pas seulement
une fois, c'est porte-parole, il
n'y a pas juste Poutine qui
part, il y a c'est porte-parole
qui parle un peu partout, les
messages sont envoyés et que
l'arme nucléaire, même si on dit
qu'on ne veut pas l'utiliser
peut être utilisé s'il y a une
menace existentielle pour la
Russie. Et c'est ce qu'on c'est
pas, qu'est-ce qui va être
considéré comme une menace
existentielle? Si c'est une
victoire de l'Ukraine, est-ce
que c'est une menace
existentielle? Où est le seuil?
Et l'OTAN qui est réunie
aujourd'hui, je pense que Louis
Blanc vous en faisait un résumé,
comment nous, l'OTAN, on peut se
préparer à cette menace la. En
Ukraine, mais contbres
aussi.
- Est-ce qu'il y aurait pas un
commando pour aller
l'assassiner?
- C'est possible, c'est très
opaque le régime en Russie. Il
dirige en colonne, en vertical
vous savez. Il n'y a pas
beaucoup de gens autour de lui
ni de successeur désigné. Même
s'il y a des gens qui pensen
que éliminer Vladimir Poutine
serait une solution pour en
finir avec cette guerre, c'est
peut-être se trompé, parce que
ça pourrait dégénérer en guerre
civile. Le pouvoir pourrait
tomber entre les mains de
quelqu'un d'encore plus
instable. Chez la population, je
ne vois pas pour leeeeeeee
risque de révolution. On dit que
les sanctions, une fois qu'elle
seront appliquées et feront mal
à la population il y aurait un
risque. Mais pour l'instant, au
sein de sa garde rapprochée est-
ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un
putsch? C'est tellement opaque
que même quand les gens
démissionnent autour de lui
celle-ci de le confirmer.
- Est-ce que ça pourrait encore
plus instable n'étant pas là?
Avoir.
Dans le plaidoyer de Poutine, il
dit qu'il veut chasser les
nazis. François Duranton vous
demande y a-t-il oui ou non une
milice néonazie en Ukraine?
- Il y a un régiment très connu
qui s'appelle régiment d'azote.
Il faut retourner dans
l'histoire pour expliquer ce
régiment. Après la prise de la
Crimée il y a eu une mince
urgence des séparatistes
prorusse à Donetsk. L'armée
ukrainienne n'étend pas ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui, parce que là
elle a été entraînée depuis des
années par les Canadiens les,
les Européens, les Américains.
Ces appels à des milices
volontaires. Parmi elles, le
régiment d'Azov. Extrême droite,
nazis. Le fondateur, combien de
gens ont rejoint ses reins? On
ne sait pas. Mais ils ont des
origines d'extrême droite qui a
été intégrée officiellement à
l'armée ukrainienne. C'est le
prétexte que se donne Vladimir
Poutine, très concret pour
convaincre la population qu'il y
a un régime nazi. Il y a un
environnement en Ukraine où il y
a de la place pour ce genre de
mouvement.
- Comme notre propagande au
mensonge, sa part d'un fond de
vérité. C'est un bel exemple.
- Ce qui est incroyable, je
parlais avec une amie à Moscou
aujourd'hui, elle dit que ce qui
est le plus déprimant c'est des
discussions que j'ai avec des
gens que je pensais bien
informer qui médise, il commence
à croire que l'Ukraine est en
train de développer des armes
chimiques avec les États-Unis.
C'est le discours du Kremlin.
- La force de la propagande.
- Extrême.
- Ils sont prêts à mourir pour
leur pays. Pour la liberté, mais
je ne sais pas si c'est parce
qu'ils avaient connu l'URSS,
mais la liberté n'est pas un
concept qui importait de
l'Ouest. On est libre et on se
bat pour le garder. Il y a une
histoire parfaite en Russie,
avec l'Union soviétique mais
très certainement, c'est un
peuple qui se soulève. Il y a eu
plusieurs tentatives de
révolution jusqu'à la révolution
du Biden où ils ont réussi à
chasser un gouvernement
prorusse. Ils ont choisi l'ouest
pour l'ouverture économique,
pour les opportunités.
- Mais aussi pour la démocratie
quand même.
- Absolument parce qu'il y a une
autocratie chez le voisin russe.
Ce qui est intéressant, les
Ukrainians ce moment se batte
pour quelque chose de très
concret. Ils se battent pour
leur vie. Les Russes, ils disent
que nous on se bat contre
quelque chose de trop gros et
trop abstrait. La réaction
serait drôlement différente le
danger était imminent. Il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont tenu
pour acquis qu'il pouvait
continuer leur vie en Russie
dans leur confort sans
conséquence. Il réalise que ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui.
- Erreur.
- Il y a plein de petites
alliées. En commençant par le
Bélarus. Il ne l'a pas annexé
mais c'est tout comme. La Chine,
il faut regarder la Chine. Ce
n'est pas anodin de reculer dans
les années, dans les dernières
années alors que la Chine se
s'isolait des États-Unis et de
la Russie. Ces deux pays se sont
réconciliés, on peut dire ça
comme ça. Jusqu'à mener des
exercices militaires conjoints.
On fait des grands spectacles
chaque année, des fois ça
Russie, des fois c'est en Chine.
On affiche clairement, fièrement
cette alliance militaire. Elle
n'est pas se démêlée en devenir.
La Chine est dans une drôle de
position en ce moment. Elle n'a
pas imposé des sanctions. Est-ce
qu'elle va fournir des armes? Va
falloir surveiller au courant
des prochaines semaines. Jeudi
semaine parce que Poutine, je
vous laisse là-dessus, le 9 mai
en Russie: toute arrête. C'est
le jour de la victoire de la
Grande guerre contre les nazis.
C'est une journée sacrée. Les
enfants sont en costume
militaire, tout le monde et
respirer. Poutine raidit à ses
généraux et à son armée qu'il
veut une victoire